[Musique]
on voit une formation en triangle avec
dollard-des-ormeaux qui lève l'épée en
vainqueur et qui à ses côtés un soldat
non identifié dans le côté et de l'autre
côté un autochtone vaincu
c'est une oeuvre du sculpteur canadien
louis philippe hébert réalisé en 1916
une scène controversée aux allures de
victoire qui commémore la défaite de
dollard-des-ormeaux en 560 contre des
iroquois
il est très stéréotypé comme tous les
personnages de l'époque il l'était et
l'autochtone aussi comme tous les
autochtones à l'époque était représenté
presque entièrement nu des plumes à la
tête
la sculpture a été réalisée pendant la
première guerre mondiale à une époque où
le gouvernement canadien avait du mal à
enrouler de jeunes soldats et l'image de
ce fougueux conquerra était utilisé pour
les recruter bluff des problématiques
mais surtout c'est l'histoire derrière
qui est problématique
louis philippe hébert quand ils créent
leur vie véhicule un message qui est on
se fout de l'autochtone on veut parler
du blanc canadiens français victorieux
qui s'engage rapidement dans une
bataille à l'issue incertaine
l'artiste était imprégné de la mentalité
de son époque et sa production avait des
visées commerciales selon le
conservateur c'est l'arrivée des
maternités des usines de
l'automatisation d'expansion des villes
du développement urbain dans ce contexte
là les autochtones étaient souvent vu un
peu comme la nature un peu comme les
arbres qu'il fallait abattre pour faire
de la place au développement
c'est l'installation de nicolas fleming
qui a créé cette maison qui est en fait
de maisons de notables de la même époque
donc fin 19e
l'oeuvre fait partie d'une collection de
22 bronze réalisée par des artistes
canadiens récemment acquise par le musée
de joliette prendre un sujet comme ça
aujourd'hui c'est risqué csq et parce
que ça fait très mal perçu ça peut être
mal vu ce choix audacieux fait quelques
années auparavant auraient pu s'avérer
désastreux ya cette dimension la vidéo
qui s'est ajoutée dans l'exposition a
débuté quelques jours seulement après la
mort de joyce et chats quad cette femme
autochtone de victimes de racisme à
l'hôpital de joliette situé à quelques
rues du musée on a travaillé que le
centre d'amitié autochtone de lanaudière
qui étant un partenaire super important
pour le musée maintien quand quelqu'un
et yvette harcelé des témoignages
d'autochtones jeunes et vieux ont été
intégrés à l'exposition le jour de
l'ouverture d'expulsion c'était le
samedi suivant la mort de jesse chaque
mois pendant lequel il y avait une
manifestation anti racisme dans un parc
à joliette
puis on passer la journée ici de façon
j'en parle j'ai la chair de poule
c'était incroyablement émouvant les ont
passé la journée ici à parler entre eux
et avec les autres visiteurs de ce
qu'ils voyaient de comment ça avait été
fait puis de l'importance croissante des
choses qui revenait souvent souvent de
l'importance d'avoir des alliés dans
cette situation là
avec cette culture le directeur du musée
de joliette a le sentiment d'ajouter une
petite pierre à l'édifice de la
réconciliation avec les premières
nations
les solutions doivent passer par au
moins un dialogue si on est capable
d'aider à lancer ce dialogue l'heure
c'est la seule chose qu'on
la sculpture de dollard des ormeaux
demeure accessible aux visiteurs
jusqu'au 2 septembre prochain
[Musique]